Sam hunt is officially taken I'm gonna  make miss clearly he did et can confirm  the 31 year old country crooner is back  with one of his exes rumors swirled a  few weeks back when Sam posted this pic  of a mystery girl in the woods with the  caption feral child and just last week  the house party singer sent fans into a  frenzy when he posted a video of said  mystery girl walking sexily toward a  beach with the caption my day one yep  fans are speculating hons day one  mystery brunette is his ex hannah lee  fowler who is also rumored to be the  inspiration for his album montevallo  well there goes our chances let's all  cry ourselves to sleep now shall we  you